[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANDRA GUO: Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
My name is Sandra Guo.
I'm a product manager
at Google Cloud.
And here with me
is Vic Iglesias.
He's a cloud
solutions architect.
So today, we're going to be
talking about secure software
supply chain on Google for
your Kubernetes workload.
Here is the agenda
for this talk.
We're going to start with an
overview of container security
and how supply chain security
fits in the bigger picture.
Then we'll talk about how supply
chain security often looks
like, the common pitfalls.
And we're going to go
over a few best practices
to help you navigate the space.
Then we're going to
introduce a few GCP
products that's going to help
you secure your supply chain.
In the end, Vic is
going to show us
a demo of how the different
products and best practices
tie together.
Let's get started.
So how is securing a container
different from securing a VM?
Let's go over a few areas.
First, surface of attack--
containers package all the
dependencies and application
needs into a nice
little package so
that you don't need as many
dependencies, libraries,
processes running
on the host image
to support the
containerized applications.
This way, you're able
to minimize the host OS
and reduce your
attack surface there.
For resource
isolation, containers
has that built in as well.
It uses namespaces and C
groups to allocate resources
for particular resources,
such as a storage
volume to a containerized
application or process.
For permissions,
just like VMs, you
want to configure fine grained
permissions with container
based applications as well.
But one big difference
there is containers
encourage microservices.
So instead of running one
giant monolithic application,
it has access to everything.
Now it's much easier to have
smaller applications having
smaller access scope as well.
So it's much easier to implement
a fine grained access control.
And then, last but
not least, lifecycle--
this is probably the
biggest difference
between containerized
applications
and VM based applications.
With containers, it's immutable.
It encourages fast deployment.
It's very developer friendly.
So now we see applications
getting released daily,
versus in the VM based
world, oftentimes,
a monolithic application doesn't
get updated for a few months.
So with this and
with microservices,
you have a lot more services to
keep track of in the production
environment, a lot
more deployment
to keep track of in the
production development.
A lot of people adopt the
continuous integration
and deployment model
to continue pushing out
new changes over time.
So for a lot of
organizations, the last piece,
the lifecycle piece,
is where most changes
needs to happen to
the infrastructure
because now you have
continuous deployments.
We have to streamline
your security checks.
And so that's going to be
the area of today's focus
for this talk.
We're going to share a few
tools, lessons, container
characteristics to
help you navigate
this migration to container
based application lifecycle
management.
So containers has a
few characteristics
that is going to enable you
to have a different security
mindset and implement a
different type of security
model that leads to better
security in the long run.
Let's go through them.
The first, containers are
short lived and frequently
redeployed.
This means that you can have
one centralized process that
apply changes to your
production workload.
And there will be less
need for direct access
to the running applications
to make any on the fly changes
because making a change
through a centralized pipeline
is as simple as
click of a button.
So you will be able to
minimize ad hoc changes
and have a unified
process for apply changes
to the production environment.
Containers are also immutable.
So instead of making
one-line changes
to a containerized
application, the intention
is to make changes to
the container as a whole.
You change one line of
code, you click a button,
and it reviews the entire
thing and redeploys
to production environment.
Now you have something
brand new running.
And the Kubernetes
infrastructure
allows deployment that
causes minimum interruption.
So you're able to apply
changes continuously.
No more Saturday 2:00 AM update
Windows necessary anymore.
Containers also enable
fast paced development.
This is oftentimes the biggest
tool to the container format
is that developers are able
to test out and push out
new changes super fast.
As the security stakeholders
and compliance stakeholders,
now every release
takes days to complete,
versus it used to take
months to complete.
So we cannot afford to
scrutinize every release
anymore-- take weeks to examine
every components of each
release.
This means that streamlined
security controls are now
necessary.
It needs to be baked into the
automated release processes
in your CI/CD pipeline.
It gets applied on the
fly so that developers
don't have to slow down and
wait for the security checks
to happen before new changes
get applied into production.
The good news is
the container format
is declarative and respectable.
It means that you don't have
to run the containers in order
to examine the content of it.
It allows you to
have more visibility
into the contents of a
container before you deploy it,
before you run it.
It also means that you can
have much better automation
on security controls
and scans to automate
those type of checks as
part of your CI/CD pipeline.
However, we have here
from a number of users
that taking care of container
security can be manual.
For most container
users that we talked to,
they have adopted
continuous integration
and continuous
deployment because it
is so developer friendly--
apply changes super quickly.
But a lot of them
are still stuck
in the old security model
where deploy controls are
applied manually.
We have stakeholders
basically manually making
sure that every release has met
all the necessary requirement.
It's also ad hoc.
The old habit is hard
to break, and we also
see that admins
and developers are
accessing running containers
directly and making changes
on the fly.
And this opens doors to
changes that are not tracked
in a centralized process.
And you have running
code that diverts
from its original deploy states,
and you can't explain or track
that using your centralized
processing pipeline.
And those kind of changes
happen at the end of a release.
It's a more reactive
model instead
of a preventative model.
So instead of controlling
what gets into a production
by making those ad
hoc manual changes,
now you're reacting
to bad things that
are happening in the production
environment in a very
manual way.
So as I mentioned,
having a CI/CD pipeline
does not stop untrusted code
from being deployed, right?
You can have a CI/CD
pipeline that has scans
and analysis enabled
and all the goodness.
But you can have a
privileged attacker.
It could be a developer
who is making a mistake.
It could also be a
compromised account
that is able to deploy code
directly to production.
And now this person is bypassing
all the checks that you have.
You no longer have total
control of what goes
into production environment.
And on top of that, if you
don't lock down your production
environment, you have
admins and developers
and privileged personnel
having direct access
to the running jobs.
And now you have another
vector of untracked changes
to your production environment.
And even for those
who have a lock down
or have a centralized
CI/CD, there
are many common pitfalls
that could happen.
In the developer phase,
people could make a mistake.
They could check in code that
contains vulnerabilities.
And their icon could be phished.
Or there could be a
malicious insider.
During the CI/CD phase, if
you have one monolithic,
super-privileged
robot account that's
running the entire
end-to-end CI/CD process,
you may experience a
confused deputy problem.
Your CI/CD pipeline may have
a bug in the testing phase,
and it gets tricked into
reading your source data
and pushing random images
to your image repository.
There could be
privileged escalation
there in the pipeline itself.
And in the deploy
stage, you could also
have trusted account that
is able to bypass the CI/CD
checks.
Having a CI/CD, again,
does not prevent
deploying on trusted code.
So what to do?
We have a few best
practices here, hopefully,
that can help you navigate
around those common pitfalls.
First, you should have a
centralized, locked-down CI/CD
process as a single choke
point for applying changes
to your production environment.
You should build images
from only trusted sources,
and you should also have
streamlined scanning
and analysis for images.
Last but not least, explicitly
verify each of the images
that you deploy to your
production environment
and have that baking as
part of your CI/CD process.
I'm going to go through
each of the best practices
and look into the details
of what exactly it requires.
But first, having a centralized,
locked-down CI/CD pipeline.
It is very beneficial
to have a single process
that every changes to your
production have to go through.
It makes it easier
to track changes.
It makes it easier to explain
to your stakeholders what
are the criteria for
production release is.
We also encourage that
you should implement least
privilege for each
of the release step.
For example, the CI
portion of the pipeline
should have a
different permission
from the CD portion
of the pipeline.
So that the stage that
is able to deploy code
to your production
environment shouldn't also
have permission to
checking code, for example,
to your repository, or
read your source code,
or checking your source code.
Don't blindly trust
your image repository.
Just because an image is checked
into your production repository
does not mean that it
can be safely deployed
to your production environment.
It could contain
vulnerabilities.
It could be outdated.
It could be from
something from a year ago.
You really want to verify
every image you deploy
to your production explicitly
at the time of the deployment.
You should also minimize ad hoc
accesses to running containers.
So there's no good having
a centralized process
if people can access your
running jobs directly.
And you need to lock
down the entire process.
There are also a few
recommended practices
that I wouldn't go into
details, such as having metadata
so you can examine later.
And it just means that
automated does not
mean the human should
not be involved.
It's always good to
have human checks
as part of your CI/CD pipeline.
Next lesson, build images
from trusted sources.
So we know that we'll look
at our food, and we're like,
is this organic?
Is this FDA approved?
Similarly, when you
build your content
or you want to make sure you
use minimum secure base images
so that you minimize your attack
surface from the beginning.
You want to whitelist
only trusted code
from your repositories
or trusted third party
repositories so that you don't
have random images downloaded
from the internet making their
way into your production job.
You should also be explicit in
your step in your Docker file,
which means that use explicit
version to not just tag
explicit version of
what it's scripting.
So when you run a Docker
viewed two days from now,
it would produce the same thing.
When you have a
problem, and you're
able to go back and
examine exactly what
it was pulled into a container.
So to help with
that best practice,
Google has a managed
base image product.
It is available in a number
of common distributions,
such as Debian, Ubuntu, CentOS.
It is hosted on
cloud marketplace.
These basic images
are maintained
by Google, used by
Google internally
on a number of our
infrastructures and products.
So keep them up to date.
We apply vulnerability
scannings to them constantly.
Whenever there is
available fixes,
we apply the latest patch.
So if you have
continuous integration,
new images get built of using
one of the managed secure base
images.
You would always pull the most
recent up to date base images
as managed by us.
This is a very convenient
way and a low effort way
to start from a clean
slate on your build side.
Lesson number three,
streamlined tests and analysis--
so as I mentioned earlier,
having a CI/CD is great.
But it's better if you have
scannings, or vettings,
or testings baked into
that so that only code
that have passed those
criterias makes their way
into production.
So simple things to do are
enable image vulnerability
scanning and have
automated integration test
stages in your CI/CD pipeline.
And it's always good to
have a QA sign-off, which
could be a human
involved step, or it
could be a manual
integration as a gatekeeper.
And there are also some
open source software
that we provide to
help you implement
additional structured
tests or image diff
to further validate the
images in your CI/CD pipeline.
To help with this lesson,
we have a container registry
vulnerability scanning
product that is available
today in beta.
What it does is every time-- so
when you enable this feature,
it looks at every
single image that you
check into your
Container Registry
to look for known
vulnerabilities
in a number of common base
images, Debian, Alpine, Ubuntu.
It's constantly contacting the
industry standard vulnerability
database to pull the most
recent vulnerabilities used
for analysis.
So every time there
is a new vulnerability
becomes available, it will
be taking into consideration
for the scans that the product
performs on your images
in the repository.
It also plugs it into
your existing tool chain,
so it publishes the
result. And then
you can use that result
for a number of purposes.
You can use it to apply deploy
time policies, for example,
to only deploy things that
meets a certain vulnerability
requirement.
You could use it for
human knowledge gathering.
If you have a
problem and you would
like to know what are the
vulnerabilities in your running
jobs, you could go
back and take a look
at all of the scanning results.
Last lesson, enforce
image deployment policy--
so that's what I
mentioned earlier.
Don't blindly trust your
production image repository.
Instead, verify every image
at the time of deployment.
So a couple things
to ensure here
is making sure that you will
deploy images that are actually
viewed by you.
You don't have a developer
downloading a BitMiner job
from the internet directly and
deploy it to your production
environment, for example.
And many of us run
third party images.
So you want to make sure you
have an explicit whitelist
for the search party images that
is allowed on your production
infrastructure.
Deploy using digest
instead of tags.
Because digests are
content addressable.
And you may be able to round--
it doesn't have the risk
to run into risk conditions,
such as if the tag gets updated
halfway through a
deployment rollout,
it also makes it easy to
examine what happened later on.
You deployed something.
You want to go back and
see exactly what happened.
Deployments and digests
makes it much easier.
We'll also recommend that
you have deployed policies
on a per production
environment basis
to maximize your flexibility.
If you want to have security
controls for your production
environment, you may have
very strict rules there
that says only deploy things
that is vulnerability free.
Only deploy things
that has QA sign-off.
But for your dev clusters or
for your staging clusters,
you may have more
lenient policies.
As long as it's viewed
by me, I'm OK to deploy.
So it's good to have
those type of policies
be declared as the
runtime environment level.
It's also very convenient to
demonstrate security controls
to stakeholders or potentially
compliance officers
to explain to them,
here are the criterias
to apply to each
of my environment.
And we're going to
demonstrate to you
in one place in a policy.
It's OK to allow human
to break this process
when there is emergencies.
But the trick there
is to always log.
There is a structure.
And humans wants to
deploy a quick fix
because things are on fire.
And if we really
don't have time to run
through the entire
pipeline, fine.
But log that and so that
you can review that later.
Also, for our vendor
images, we recommend
that you deploy those directly
from cloud marketplace.
So you know that those are
authentic images coming
directly from the vendor.
So for this lesson, we have a
binary authorization product
that will help with it.
It's also currently
in beta on GCP.
So what binary
authorization does
is it integrates with different
stages in your CI/CD pipeline.
So as the image passes
through each of the stage,
it requires a signature
signifying that the image has
passed that particular stage.
And by the time the image gets
to be deployed to production,
final authorization is
integrated to the GKE
deployment API to
check that does
this image have all
the required signatures
that customer has
set in the policy.
So this way, even if you have
a privileged individual that
is trying to bypass
your pipeline,
even though that he
has the permission
to deploy to your
production environment,
he will not be able to because
the code that he is deploying
does not have the
necessary signature on it.
And any failed attempt to
deploy to a binary solution
enabled cluster
gets auto logged.
So you can review all
the events later on.
In addition to
signature verification,
we also support
explicit whitelisting.
So your security
admin can maintain
a centralized third party
image whitelist that says,
I only trust this
version of an NGX.
I only trust this version
of a Ruby on Rails.
And if you have a
developer that is trying
to use it accidentally or
maliciously deploy something
that is older, outdated,
or has vulnerability,
he would not be able
to because, again, it's
not explicitly whitelisted.
So I told you about four best
practices and a few products
to help with the best practice.
But here it is
all tied together.
You have one
centralized pipeline.
And you can use a
secure minimum base
image that feed into
your centralized builder.
Once your image gets
checked into the repository,
it gets automatically scanned.
And then it gets deployed
subject to a deploy policy
that you control.
If it passes the
deploy policy, great.
It's a trusted image.
It goes to production.
If not, untrusted image
gets logged into auto log
and for future review.
And here are the
three features on GCPs
that I told you about that
are available for usage now.
We'll have a Google-managed,
secure, minimal base image
that gets updated continuously
that you can just directly pull
that into your computer.
It will have a
vulnerability scanning
that's baked into
the Google Container
Registry that
happens automatically
for every image you check in.
We have a binary authorization
to enforce this deployed policy
to your runtime environment to
make sure that only images you
trust get to go in there.
And now Vic will show you
how the different pieces
tie together in action.
VIC IGLESIAS: All right,
let's give it up for Sandra
for dropping some
knowledge right there.
Yes.
SANDRA GUO: Thank you.
VIC IGLESIAS: Spectacular.
If we could switch over to--
all right, so I'm going to demo
a lot of what Sandra talked
about as far as best practices
through a CI/CD pipeline
with a sample application.
In my case, I have a frontend
and a backend service
that I'm going to deploy
independently into Kubernetes.
And it's going to go
through this pipeline,
very similar to what
Sandra just showed.
So we're going to have
a developer environment.
Then we're going to
commit some code that's
going to be picked up by SI.
We're going to
create some images
and some Kubernetes
manifests that are then
going to be deployed
by Spinnaker, which is
our continuous deployment tool.
You'll notice we have
two different tools
and two different identities
for our CI and CD here.
SANDRA GUO: This is
lesson number one,
centralized lockdown.
VIC IGLESIAS: She's
got all the policies.
She told me how to
build this thing.
So then we're going to
deploy into staging,
and then have an approval,
and go into production.
So as far as the logical view of
the CI/CD pipeline, where we're
going to bake in some
checks is to make sure
after we trigger our commit,
that we pass unit tests.
So we don't want any code
going into production
that hasn't passed unit tests.
So this is where we're going to
add one of those check points
that the binary authorization
API lets us add.
And we're going to add that
for our passing unit tests.
Once it's passed
unit tests, we're
going to build our
container image,
push it to the
container registry,
and in there, it's
automatically going to kick off
a vulnerability scan.
The next thing we're going to
do is add a attestation or one
of these signatures
that says that there
were no critical
vulnerabilities in that image.
Once that's been
detected by Spinnaker,
it's going to deploy
at the staging,
and we're going to add
another signature there,
another attestation that
says that we've actually
passed through the staging
process and somebody
has clicked this is good to go.
And then we're going to go ahead
and deploy into production.
Through this demo,
we're also going
to try to bypass our
security in two ways.
One is by committing some
vulnerable code as a developer,
this can happen to anybody.
And then the other one is
having our credentials phishes,
maybe through some
social engineering,
or something like that.
Or just, you left your
laptop open and someone
can access your credentials.
We're going to try
to deploy directly
into our production cluster.
We'll see what that looks like.
All right, so I have
a Cloud Shell here.
I have my source code available.
It's a going app.
Like I said before, it's got
a backend and a frontend.
And I'm just going to run a
command called skaffold dev.
And that's going to
actually build my container,
push it to the registry,
and then deploy
my manifest into my GKE cluster
that I'm using for development.
So here I can see that
skaffold has deployed.
It's actually doing some
port forwarding for me,
so I should be able to
access it directly from here.
Cool.
So this is my
development version.
We're going to try to walk
through the happy path
of the CI/CD pipeline.
So let's say that
I'm a developer,
and I want to change from blue
to green because some product
manager decided that
green is in right now.
And so what we're going
to notice down here
is skaffold has detected that
I've changed my source code.
And it's going to
do that loop again.
It's going to rebuild my code.
It's going to push
out an image and then
redeploy into my development
Kubernetes cluster.
That's just completed.
And now it's going to do
the port forwarding again.
And we should be able to see
our changes show up shortly
inside of our dev environment.
There we go.
Great.
So green-- green looks great.
Let's go ahead and
commit this code.
Make it green.
And push it.
And as soon as I
push it, it's going
to be detected by our CI system.
In this case, we're using
Cloud build, which is
going to detect a git commit.
Let's go ahead and
see if that's started.
Great.
So it detected a change
to my backend image.
And it started the process.
And here, what it's
going to do is first
build the container image.
It's going to have it
locally, and then we're
going to start tests.
And as we're testing it, it's
going to push that image up
to our Container Registry.
When it gets into the
Container Registry,
it's automatically going to
kick off a vulnerability scan.
And in the meantime,
we're also going
to add our attestation,
our signature that
says we have passed
unit tests if we
have gone through these phases.
So we can see here, the build
has completed or is about to.
And then we're going to go
ahead and push that image.
While that's happening, we
can go ahead and check out
what our binary authorization
policies look like.
Sandra talked about
having policies
centralized for our various
projects and clusters.
So here I can define my policy.
If we go into the
edit pane here,
we can see that by
default in this project,
I allow all images, but then
I have cluster specific rules
that I can add.
Another thing that I can
do is have a dry run mode,
where I add a pretty
enforcing policy.
But I don't actually
reject them.
I just log into
Stackdriver login.
So for my production cluster,
I have a specific rule here.
And that's going
to say that I have
to have these signatures
of these attestations added
into my image before it can
be deployed into this cluster.
And that is my
production cluster.
So I have to make sure that
I have my unit tests passed,
my vulnerabilities are checked
and there are no critical ones,
and that I've passed through
the staging manual operation.
So that's my kind
of default policy.
I can also add exemptions.
And one of the
exemptions I can do
is say, anything that's
provided by Google as part of us
running your GKE
clusters, for example,
we're just going to allow.
And that's this
list of images here.
But I also added one for a thing
that I added to my cluster.
In this case, I
added calico, and I
want to make sure that calico
can run inside that cluster.
So I whitelisted that
particular path for images.
Let's go ahead and take a look.
OK, so CI has passed,
and now we should
be able to go back
and check our images.
Whoops.
There we go.
So here's my backend image.
All right, so I just uploaded
that image and ran the scan.
And there was no
vulnerabilities found.
In here, Spinnaker has picked
up that that image was created
or was pushed.
And it started to check that
vulnerability scan result.
And this is where you can
start to, in automation,
interpret the results
of a vulnerability scan.
It's not necessarily
the case that every CVE
is a problem for
your CI/CD process
or for your particular
application.
So you might whitelist some
things or things like that.
In my case, what I do is I set
a threshold for the CVSS score
that is given to each
CVE that's in an image.
And if there are any
that are above five,
I make sure to block the
pipeline from running.
And we'll see that
in a little bit.
Now that my vulnerability
check has passed
and I have no
vulnerabilities that
are over my threshold,
which was five,
it should be deploying
into staging.
And I should see staging
is now rolling out
with the green version.
As the release manager
and only person,
frankly, running
this pipeline, I
can go ahead and see that I've
got my manual judgment here.
And it gives me links to
maybe my metrics dashboard.
I'm going to check
on some key metrics
that I need to check for
performance, for example,
the latency of the application.
I can view the sites for
staging and production.
But I'm just going to
continue because I've already
checked that our staging looked
good, and it had the green.
And then that's going to
add another attestation
that I've actually asserted that
this pipeline can move forward.
With that, we should have
production showing up
with green shortly.
Now I wanted to show
what would happen
if I checked in a
vulnerability as a developer.
So let's say that
in my Docker file,
I'm using Alpine, which
is a pretty minimal image.
And that's pretty awesome.
But I find that I need some
new library or something that
is not available in
the Alpine image.
So I want to switch to Ubuntu.
And I have an Ubuntu
Docker file that I create.
I'm using Ubuntu 18.04.
It seems like a
reasonable thing to do.
And I just change that
here to use the Ubuntu one.
And that's going to screw me up.
Oh, boy.
Typing on this thing can be
difficult. OK, there we go,
Ubuntu.
Great.
So now I want to use
that Ubuntu Docker file.
I've got my change here.
And I'm going to use that
Ubuntu and push it back
through my pipeline.
All right.
And as I push that, we'll see
the same kind of flow kick off.
And we'll notice
one main difference
when we're checking
the vulnerabilities.
So again, if I go
back here, I should
see that Cloud
Build has started,
and it's going to
build my image.
And then we'll see how Spinnaker
reacts differently to that.
The other type of compromise
that I wanted to show you
and how we would block
that in our cluster
is if my credentials
were phished.
And someone wants to
maybe launch a shell
into my production cluster.
So let's say I go to
my production cluster.
And I check out
what pods I have,
which I have access to do.
I have my frontend and
backend pods in there,
but I want to run just
a shell using Ubuntu,
so I say image ubuntu: 16.04.
Great.
And I'm the hacker man.
So I'm going to
call it hackerman.
I just want to get a
shell into this cluster
and poke around a little bit.
So we see here
that the deployment
was actually created.
So that might be unexpected
for some folks that
are familiar with Kubernetes.
As we refresh here and
see the workloads that
are in our production
cluster, you
can see here that hacker man
was actually not allowed.
While the deployment
was created,
it was actually prevented from
creating any pods because it
does not have those
at the stations
that we defined in our policy.
So now we've subverted the
production cluster attack
by ensuring that we have
our policy set properly
in our project.
Let's go check in on our
Cloud Build setup here.
Looks like things are
still building and pushing.
Once that's complete,
we should see
it show up in our
vulnerability scans here.
I'll just go back
and check the images.
While that image is
finishing pushing out,
we're going to actually look
at what we can see inside
of Stackdriver logging about
that event of a user actually
trying to hack into our cluster.
So in here, I should shortly
see that-- here we go.
So we have a bunch
of events that we
can use to alert maybe off of
this that show that someone
was trying to run on this
Ubuntu 16.04 in our production
cluster.
And they didn't have all
of these attestations
that we had defined.
So you can use this as a way to
alert yourself of any issues.
Over here, we should see
the push is complete.
And now we have a
scan that started.
And I didn't have to do
anything other than turn
on the vulnerability scan API.
And now all of my images are
automatically being scanned.
And shortly, I should
see a nice report
telling me all of the
scans that are in here.
So once that's complete, we
should get a nice report.
And Spinnaker is probably
already kicked off
and started to check for
those vulnerabilities.
So it's actually verifying
that our vulnerabilities are--
that we have minimal
vulnerabilities.
So you can see here it's waiting
for the vulnerability scan
to complete.
If we refresh, it should
have this complete.
All right.
So now we can see in
here, a big difference
from our Alpine image.
The Ubuntu image has
a lot more in it.
We can see that there
are many CVEs in here
and many of them above my
CVSS threshold of five.
So Spinnaker should detect that
and block this from running.
So if I check out
the output again,
it should have waited
for it to complete.
It finished.
And now it lists out all of
the vulnerabilities that I had,
and I can see that there
are many above 5.o,
which was my threshold.
And it's blocked my pipeline.
So in this demo, you've
seen CI/CD pipeline
with various elements using
both vulnerability scanning
and binary authorization
to lock down
what can go into a
production environment.
If we can go back to slides
here, Sandra, I think you're--
SANDRA GUO: Yep.
VIC IGLESIAS: All right.
SANDRA GUO: Yeah, Victor
showed us the lessons and tools
in action.
So what are the takeaways?
What are the quick things that
you can get started and enable
in pipeline tonight?
Right?
First, you can minimize
access to your CI/CD pipeline.
Get rid of the people that
really don't need access
to your CI/CD
pipeline so that you
have a minimum set of people.
And if you have time,
separate the service
account you use for
CI from CD so you
have some segregation
of responsibilities
in your pipeline.
Have minimal permissions
set up there.
But at least minimize the
number of people having
access to your CI/CD pipeline.
Second, if you haven't yet, use
a Google managed secure base
image as your base image
in your built pipeline.
So instead of using Alpine
directly or Ubuntu directly,
using the Google
managed version of it
so that it gets automatically
updated and patched every time
you push something
new to production.
It's built using the
latest safe version.
Turn on GCR
vulnerability scanning.
This is the easiest one.
It's literally just one click.
If you use Google
Container Registry,
turn it on and see all the scary
vulnerabilities start spilling
out and telling you
of all the bad things
that are in your image.
Now at least you have the
information to process
and potentially act on.
Last, enforce a
builder signature
with banner authorization.
So this is sort of the
simplest deploy policy
that you can have.
Make sure that the
image you deploy
is actually built by you.
All right.
So here are some
additional resources
to learn more about the
tools and best practices
that we talked about today.
The slides will be
online at some point
after the presentation
so you don't have
to memorize a short length.
And here are some additional
container security talks
at Next that you can go check
out today and the next two
days.
[MUSIC PLAYING]